Brody Stephens who is a comedian is one
of my favorite comedians if you don't
know his stuff you got a look at him
furthermore if you're in LA you have to
go see him he's really great live but
he's also great just if you look up
clips Brody Stevens is his name Steven
Brody Stephens for some [ __ ] reason
he's got two Stevens in this name and
he's this comedian that goes on stage
and he really like he'll do jokes but
then in the middle he'll be like you
know I've worked for this spot I parked
for free and [ __ ] like that he's just
hilarious and silly I'm one time on New
Year's the New Year's crowds are always
weird and he was going on and he was
gonna be the guy who went on at the at
the Comedy Store when the ball dropped
he was gonna bring in the new year and
he was like and the crowd wasn't really
receptive to him and he said you guys
have to laugh I'll ruin your New Year's
just like this kind of guy he's really
funny anyway
The Comedy Store spots are 15 minutes
each so he went on and he at this time
he was going on a late like he would go
on at like [ __ ] it was like probably
twelve fifteen or something so he was
going on and there were about 12 people
in the audience okay and he went on and
he was bombing because there were 12
people in the audience and he was just
being weird or whatever by the end of
the 15 minutes he was there had more
people came into the showroom like
people wanted to come in from outside
and just be like ah the Comedy Store
let's catch a show he started doing
really well but this guy came in in the
middle of the act and was drunk and
Brody started making fun of him and he
started killing he started murdering
right and now there were like 35 people
there and now all the comedian's were
watching and Brody really started
murdering and in my head I was like this
is one of the best that's I've ever seen
so far okay so it came time for Brody to
bring up the next comedian who was rusty
Dooley I don't know if you know who he
is and rusty was there but Brody was
killing so hard that when Brody was like
that's my time everyone was like no no
no stay so rusty from the back of the
room was like I
look just you know what you're killing
just [ __ ] do my spot - there's no
reason for me to come up there everyone
loves you why not [ __ ] have your have
another set do another 15 minutes
[ __ ] it so everyone was like yeah do it
do it and Brody is like only if it's
okay with you rusty and rushes like yeah
as long as I get paid my [ __ ] $15 I
don't give a [ __ ] and Brody's like all
right [ __ ] it I'll do another set and
everyone's like yeah so Brody starts
doing this next set now rusty Dooley
said now he's on stage for 15 more
minutes 30 minutes he starts more people
come in the room because of this you
know people like hey he's doing he's
doing rusty set now - rusty gibbon time
really yeah he's killing when Don says
so now the room is getting full it's
like half-full and Brody is Bob now
because there's more people in it he is
lighting this place up it is the whole
room is completely turned around and
he's killing even harder and I'm
thinking this is even the better set
that I just seen right so he's murdering
so now 30 seconds goes by now this guy
he's built a rapport with this drunk guy
he's still there the guys becoming kind
of part of the set other people are
involved laughing out the guy laughing
with Brody
yeah laughing Brody and then the next
person on because Brody is like okay
guys I did two sets now I've gotta go I
gotta bring up the next comedian I don't
remember the name of the next comedian
she was this comedian that used to come
to Comedy Store did late-night spots and
she I haven't seen her in years
[ __ ] her name is her name escapes me
but she says Brody look just do my spot
- you're [ __ ] killing there's no
reason for me to do it as long as I can
get my $15 on give a [ __ ] he's like no
it's not fair comedians work hard you
all earned this spot she's like I don't
give a [ __ ] go and everyone's like
literally like come on Brody come on and
then Brody's like no no no I'm not I
gotta get offstage it's not fair I want
to let her do her spot so he goes to
leave the stage and everyone in the room
is like no stay don't like comic
and comics and and people and the drunk
guys I don't [ __ ] leave like yelling
right and I'm thinking how the [ __ ] is
this girl gonna follow this guy right so
you know so as he steps off stage he
stops like he's thinking about it you
know it's like WWF or wwww whatever the
[ __ ] and he's just thinking about it and
then what it always happens is when bro
you took the stage he used to play this
song by Paramore I don't know what it
was as some [ __ ] guitars it was like
the [ __ ] back in black song that I
play like something like that like
whatever they're big big big [ __ ] hit
was and as he's thinking it over the
music guy hits that song right so that
[ __ ] song comes on and starts [ __ ]
you know whatever that beat is everyone
screaming and that beat happens and then
Brody hears the song and pivots and
grabs the microphone and says you know
what dreams do come true and and he's
like I'm staying and everyone is on
their feet just going [ __ ] yeah and
he does another 15 minutes and I [ __ ]
you not
destroys even harder than he was this is
three sets now he did 45 minutes and I
sat and watched the whole [ __ ] thing
and it was so [ __ ] funny and I
remember in that night I I was I was the
comedian who wasn't on TV who was just
at the Comedy Store and iced by the way
still feel fortunate that I'm there and
I'm just I still feel lucky to be there
but in that moment I was like wow this
place I am so [ __ ] lucky I just get
to even just be in there let alone go
onstage late at night he was [ __ ] so
awesome and it was like yeah I hate him
people say [ __ ] like this but it really
felt like the only the only places could
happen is the Comedy Store